- Let's just start the
show to our first guest.
I am so excited.
You know him from 'Brooklyn Nine Nine',
'Everybody Hates Chris',
and dancing with his chest muscles
whenever he gets a chance.
But most importantly,
you know him as the host
of the best competition
show on television,
'America's Got Talent', and soon to be
'America's Got Talent All Stars'.
(audience cheering)
He also has a brand new
children's book out,
it's called, 'Terry's Crew'.
Please welcome my friend,
my buddy, Terry Crews!
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- Yes!
- [Howie] Feels good, huh?
(audience cheering)
- That never gets old, buddy.
- It never gets old!
- That never gets old.
Don't you think that's amazing that his,
you got talent.
Not only that, I should
talk about this just for,
I'll just start off, and then
we'll talk about other things.
But, you always do the flexing.
- Always.
- You always do that flexing,
right?
- Always, always.
- And I noticed at work, at 'AGT',
you taught Simon how to do it.
You taught Heidi how to do it.
- Yes, Heidi is really good at it.
- She tells me she can do it.
I'm not allowed to see whether she can.
- No, we've never seen it.
- Our eyes are here.
- We've never seen it.
- I've never have seen it.
- But, she's really good.
- How did you teach them,
and why did you teach them?
- Because, it's such an attention getter.
And you gotta understand, the older I get,
the better it's gonna be,
because they get saggy,
and then they just start to
fly up a little bit more.
- Really?
- So, it's gonna be good.
But all you have to do,
and this is the technique,
and anybody in the world can do it.
If you put your hands together,
and you just squeeze, squeeze.
- Oh, look, everybody.
- Squeeze your hands together
and you can feel, it's moving.
- [Howie] Wow, it's amazing.
See, now everybody's got talent.
- The way I started and
learned how to do that
is because I was really lonely.
I'm not kidding, I was like 12 years old.
There was no dates.
I was sitting at ho at home alone,
I was looking in the
mirror, and I was like,
"Oh, oh wow."
You know, 12 year old
boys come up with some
really ridiculous things.
- When your only friends
are your two nipples,
that is really lonely.
So, Happy New Year to you buddy.
- Thank you.
- And, your resolution, somebody said,
was to go to the gym? (chuckles)
- Yeah, yeah.
- Are you serious?
- First of all, I have the resolution
that takes care of itself every year.
'Cause I've been going to the
gym straight for 30 years.
I'm like, "Okay, go to
the gym for 31 years."
So now it's like, the next year.
- But you go to the gym.
So, this guy works harder
than anybody I've ever seen.
You always have like 90 projects.
There's so much more to tell.
You are so much more than what people see.
And we're gonna talk about
more of that when we come back.
(audience cheering)
Okay, Terry.
How excited are you?
We're doing 'AGT All Stars'
right now, it's on tonight.
You are brilliant at hosting that show,
because not only are you moving
this freight train along,
but you are consoling
people who didn't rise
to whatever they believe
the occasion needed to
have them rise to.
You are a cheerleader to these people.
How excited are you?
We're doing 'AGT All Stars'
right now, it's on tonight.
(audience cheering)
- It's so incredible.
It's incredible.
Now, you have to understand.
And I know you've given me
a great compliment here,
but I have to tell you, I am a fan first.
I am a fan of entertainers.
The courage, I mean,
everything that it takes
to become an entertainer in this business.
Be it dancing, singing,
comedy, all this stuff.
I'm always gleaning
knowledge from every act
that comes on that show.
Because they take me to another level.
I'm literally watching
the courage that it takes
for a little 10 year old to go sing
in front of millions of people.
I couldn't have done that when I was 10.
And so, I look at this stuff and I'm like,
I have to support it.
I have to be behind it.
And I want to give them
everything they need,
to be their best.
- [Howie] You give them
more than they need.
I'll tell you.
- For real.
- On 'All Stars', all the
people that you know and love,
from all over the world, who have won
and come close to winning, come back.
People like Terry Fator, and Kodi Lee.
But, you know, Avery,
- Avery Dixon!
- Yeah.
Your golden buzzer from this year.
When you see a young man hit the stage
and not be sure about his place in life,
let alone on our stage.
I watched him, and I
think a big part of it
was because of you and
the words of encouragement
that you give him.
I watched this kid just
blossom into, I believe,
is a future superstar.
But into the human being and the man
that he never dreamed of
being, because of you.
- But, isn't it amazing to watch?
The first time he came
out there he was in tears
because he was being bullied at school.
He had no confidence in his talent.
And then to turn around and become one of
the premier saxophonist
in the Country right now.
He's only 21 years old,
and he could be the best
ever by the time he's done.
(audience clapping)
You know what I mean?
That's what 'AGT' does.
- He didn't want to be on the show.
His mother signed him up for the show.
He couldn't even talk,
and now you are,
legitimately, his big brother.
- I am.
- [Howie] And you are there
for him.
And you could see that connection.
- And, he's back on 'All Stars'.
- [Howie] Yes, he's back on 'All Stars'.
- Which is so amazing.
- By just watching you.
(audience clapping)
We have a great time on 'AGT'.
What is, Simon and Heidi aren't
here to defend themselves,
- Let's talk about it.
- Let's spill some tea.
But it is a weird place.
- Let's feel a tangerine, for Simon.
- That's another thing.
Simon is always, I don't know.
You gotta watch the show really closely,
'cause he's always just
finishing the tangerine.
But, his whole chair is
just filled with peels.
- Just peels.
Everybody's trying to get what it is.
It smells all nice and effervescent
over there, like citrus.
- That's me.
But Simon is also.
No, I'm effervescent and citrus.
It is just a fun place to be.
That brings me to the
book that you just wrote.
Because people look at you,
and you seem like the
tough guy and the big guy.
And you talk in the book about
what it means to be tough.
Right?
- Yes.
- Talk a little bit about that.
They want me to hold up the book.
Oh, here it is.
- Oh, it's first of all,
- Here it is.
- Where I'm from,
- Where am I, there.
- I'm from Flint, Michigan,
and there was a whole
thing about being tough.
And being tough was about
being able to beat people up,
being able to intimidate people,
being able to be this
big dude on the block.
But I found that being tough was really
all about helping people.
It was really about helping
people reach their goals.
And I remember having to have this shift,
and this is one reason why
I write books all the time,
simply because all my books
are to my 12 year old self.
And 'Terry's Crew' was really about me
holding onto my dreams,
but more importantly,
finding the people that supported me.
I dedicate this book to my art teacher.
His name was, Dwight Eichelberg.
And he believed in me when
I didn't believe in myself.
He filled out all the applications,
took pictures of my artwork,
and got me two different scholarships.
And I was like, "What
are you talking about?"
(audience clapping)
And he was like,
"Terry, you can do it."
"You are amazing."
"I believe in you."
And I couldn't believe.
And I remember he was a corn farmer
from rural Michigan, and
everybody called him corny.
They were like, "Oh, Mr.
Eichelberg's so corny."
But he was like, "Terry," he said,
"you are better than I am,
and I want to see that you make it."
And I'm like,
- Wow.
it's really what this is about.
It's about finding the
people that believe in you
and can help you get there.
That's what 'Terry's Crew' is all about.
And this is what I want
everybody out there,
- Support.
- kids and adults, to know.
- The support.
(audience clapping)